the speech last night was absolutely
pathetic
if anybody
is still taking these people seriously
if anybody
is still heeding their guidelines which
are actually mandates
then that person is a dope and
most of us i think figured this out
quite a while ago once that two weeks
became
three weeks four weeks two months six
months eight months we i think a lot of
us realized
oh this is not
exactly what we were told this is oh
okay we're gonna stop paying attention
to these guys
when all the guidance kept changing day
by day by day i think a lot of us said
i think i'm going to ignore this now joe
biden
is carrying this on it would seem to me
because he needs to burnish his legacy
president trump did everything that one
can do
as pertains to the virus before he left
office
right slowing the spread that worked
they slowed the spread
uh preventing the two million deaths
within a year that we were told could
happen
yeah prevented that obviously it was the
number was much lower than that
developed a vaccine we were told by
people such as joe biden
that there was no way that trump could
direct a vaccine initiative in the
small window of time that he said he
would we did get the vaccine in that
window of time
so he did everything now joe biden says
gosh what's there for me to do i need i
need to seem like
trump screwed up coronavirus and i
succeeded on coronavirus
so he's offering us something really
really big really important if you're
driving i would stop if you're standing
i would sit down right now here's big
joe biden's big innovation to help us
all survive coronavirus at the time when
every adult is eligible in may
we will launch with our partners new
tools to make it easier for you to find
the vaccine and where to get the shot
including a new website that will help
you first find the place
to get vaccinated and the one nearest
you
stop the presses
we gotta i i need to stop my show right
now i need to process this huge news
that joe biden's going to make a web
page
joe biden the president of the united
states has
more resources at his fingertips than
anybody in the world he
is going to make a web page and what
on top of that you're going to get a web
page from the same people who brought
you the obamacare web page
so i don't hire me to make the web page
and i will go to wordpress and i will
make
a more successful web page than probably
the federal government will
uh not so much isn't that that's that's
not so much of a big
advance on the fight against coronavirus
then
what's next we we're going to get a web
page because we all need to get the
vaccine it was very
interesting how much of a focus biden
put on you have to get the vaccine you
need to get all your friends to get the
vaccine everyone needs to get the
vaccine
but also of course you need to keep
wearing masks that's just the science
too often we've turned against one
another
a mask the easiest thing to do to save
lives
sometimes it divides us so our message
to you is this
listen to dr fauci one most
distinguished and trusted voices in the
world
can you believe that masks it's so easy
it's so obvious
saves lives so you should just instantly
this is the first thing you should be
doing
that divides us that's become a divisive
question because people
don't listen to dr fauci the guy who
told us not to wear masks
now in the united states people should
not be walking around
with masks you're sure of it because
people are listening really no
closely to this right now people should
not be white there's no reason to be
walking around with a mask
when you're in the middle of an outbreak
wearing a mask might make people
feel a little bit better and it might
even block
a droplet but it's not providing the
perfect protection that people think
that it is and often there are
unintended consequences people keep
fiddling with the mask and they keep
touching their face
can you believe people are so divided
and they
they won't do the obvious sensible thing
and wear the mask
the people who are listening to dr fauci
who told them not to now dr vaccio of
course changed his mind on this
later he said no you really you should
wear the mask definitely wear the mask
and his reasoning for his his past
advice
was that he wanted to keep enough masks
for the healthcare workers
so he said yeah we didn't want you
peasants to take up all the good masks
we wanted those to be for the
the people in public health so but now
we have enough masks so now
yeah actually you totally should wear
masks everything i said before
just wasn't true so don't don't believe
that okay
regardless of your stance on the masks
if you're still wearing this filthy
cloth over your face in public like a
sheep
you know my views of it but regardless
let's say you wear it you want to do it
you want to
do what joe biden says does joe biden
not understand why people
might be a little skeptical because the
single
expert that he is holding up
as the the credible man here for the
credibles common sense advice
he's the one who not only first told us
not to wear them but
then admitted that he misled us he
admitted that he was acting in a way
that was political
and actually obscuring the scientific
reality now beyond
the masks beyond the website joe biden
knows we're gonna get through these dark
dark times in our country
by washing our hands we're seizing this
moment
in history i believe will record we
faced and overcame one of the toughest
and darkest periods in this nation's
history
darkest we've ever known we need
everyone to get vaccinated
we need everyone to keep washing their
hands
stay socially distanced and keep wearing
the mask
as recommended by the cdc
statesmanship in 19 1940s
winston churchill we shall go on we
should fight on the beaches and
in the streets we shall never surrender
statesmanship in 2021 where the mask
where the hat wear the mask wash your
hands
you got to wash your hands use soap and
water
warm water not cold water cold water is
not going to kill all the germs
got to wear the mask gotta wash your
hands
the notion that this is the darkest
time in american history forgive me if i
think it's a little hyperbolic is it not
a little hyperbolic
the civil war it was pretty dark wasn't
it world war
ii both of the world wars pretty dark
time in our history
the i'm not i don't mean to downplay the
china cough
it's bad it is bad it really is bad
worse than that worse than the civil war
i don't
i don't think so i don't think he's
convincing anybody
meanwhile you've got these social
repercussions like the schools right the
schools
are still shut down kids rates of
anxiety depression even suicide are
spiking in a lot of places because they
can't see their friends they can't leave
their home they're stuck in their little
pods
joe biden he he's going to figure a way
out of this
watching a generation of children who
may be set back up to a year or more
because they've not been in school
because of their loss of learning
it's the details of life that matter the
most
and we missed those details the big
details on the small moments
weddings birthdays graduations
all the things that needed to happen but
didn't
yeah we're missing those because of you
and your political cronies
we should have reopened schools months
ago even the public health experts said
we should reopen schools months ago
you won't let us because you're in the
pocket of the teacher unions
because of your purely political
calculations because you
and all the other sociopath politicians
have exploited
the flu or you know the virus
to seize an unprecedented amount of
power in this country
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you